thanks david uh yeah so
this was my first slide and uh david you
should borrow this slide
right so the holy grail of
pseudorandomness well you just
you probably saw this talk already
what i'm going to talk about is the
other holy grail of pseudorandomness
so
what is this
well
let's say it's a pseudorandom generator
that takes a random seed of length log n
and stretches it into n bits that look
truly random to any small circuit say a
circuit of size n squared okay
so
this of course would imply that p equals
bbp and randomness doesn't add much
power to computation in the big picture
why would we believe that such you know
magical objects should exist
well this long and beautiful line of
work
tells us starting with the observation
of yav then nissan vikderson impalia
zobigdersen
it tells us that if sufficiently strong
lower bounds hold we think they should
then in fact such pseudorandom
generators exist right extremely strong
speedrun generators
but on the other hand
proving
that a prg actually fools a class of
functions it's a pretty strong you know
it's a pretty strong disc to that class
it gives very explicit lower bounds for
that class of functions so this also
tells us that we are unlikely to find
this holy grail anytime soon
okay
given the state of affairs what could be
hoped to do
what is the hope for unconditional
construction of pseudorandom generators
well certainly when you have a specific
algorithm in mind you could hope to
mitigate or completely eliminate the use
of randomness for that particular
algorithm this doesn't require any lower
bounds this is a program which has had
some spectacular successes like primes
as in p and the sd connectivity
algorithm
in other settings like hash functions
and streaming algorithms
getting short random strings is actually
crucial for algorithmic efficiency
because usually in hash functions or
streaming algorithms you're thinking of
some input which is like the number of
documents on the world wide web or
something like that you really don't
want to store an explicit random
function on this larger input right so
here pseudorandomness is essential to
say the space complexity of these
functions this is something which is
going to be very relevant to the stock
today
the other thing you could hope to do is
to actually construct explicit prgs for
those classes of functions where we do
know explicit lower bounds right because
here you know if you have lower bound
sure you could hope to actually
construct
unconditional prgs this is a program
which has met with considerable success
in the case of bounded depth circuits
starting with the work of iotypic dersin
and space-bounded algorithms right so
bounded depth circuits we have lower
bonds against these and for space
bounded algorithms the right model of
computation happens to be read once
where you just stream over the random
bits so again lower bonds are not really
an issue with this model
okay
so now we could ask at least for these
classes where we do have lower bounds
do we now know how to construct optimal
pseudorandom generators which have seed
length login
and you know you probably all know that
the answer is not really not quite yet
for space bounded algorithms log space
algorithms there's a long and beautiful
line of work you know this breakthrough
result of nissan from the 90s which gave
seed length log squared n
now i don't want to give the impression
that all these papers after that did
nothing much you know they're all very
nice papers many of the authors are in
the audience so i won't say that but the
best seed length is still log squared in
right
what about ac 0 circuits well let's just
focus even on dnfs which are depth 2
circuits
here again the best prgs we have now
you'd think that these are dnfs this
presume would be nothing interesting new
to prove about them but that's not the
case again the best pseudo-random
generators we have for them have seed
length log squared in
okay
and now
you could ask well are these the
important open problems or the important
close problems in pseudorandomness how
important is it to get this log squared
n down to a log n right
well many of you are here for a semester
long program on fine grained complexity
measures so presumably you already
believe that you know getting the exact
polynomial
is important
but some others you know if you're just
here for a week you know let me try and
justify it to you why we should actually
care about this
well if you manage to get the seed
length down to log in for bounded space
algorithms this is one way you could
hope to prove that rl equals l that
randomness doesn't require doesn't you
know drastically reduce the memory
requirement of an algorithm which is an
important goal of computational
complexity
similarly
we do have lower bonds for ac 0 but we
could have better lower bonds than the
ones we do currently
and in fact this seemingly innocuous
problem of constructing a better prg for
dnfs in fact even if you get a hitting
set generator which beats this log
squared in it would lead to a better
lower bound against depth 3 ac 0 right
ok
so what is today's talk about
well i'm not going to solve either of
these problems but i'm going to show you
a technique called the gradually
independence the gradually increasing
independence paradigm
what it is is an iterative technique for
constructing and analyzing pseudorandom
generators it more or less came up
independently in these two works by kane
mecca and nelson on derandomizing the
johnson linden's trust lemma and celeste
rhinegold reader and segev on hash
functions for load balancing
and by now so you know this is a long
laundry list of things
what it does is give us optimal
constructions of pseudorandom generators
for a large class of simple functions
which we needed to fool first in order
to make any progress on these two
questions either fooling rl or fooling
ac 0 circuits so we're going to see some
of these in greater detail so just some
highlights i mentioned johnson
lindestross and load balancing it for
things like combinatorial rectangles it
gives you optimal families of min wise
hash functions gives you a prg for half
spaces and so on and so forth
now when i say optimal seed length it
leads to seed length which is
logarithmic
in all the relevant parameters which is
the input length n and the error epsilon
that you're trying to achieve when i do
this i'm hiding some log log n factors
you know and i'm going to do this
throughout the talk
um
if you care about this then go talk to
raghu after this talk
so um
and so why is this an interesting thing
well it turns out that you know
prior to this there weren't really a
whole lot of natural classes of
functions where we could really get the
right seed length in terms of both
n and the error parameter epsilon like
the really important example we knew was
epsilon biased sets these we've known
how to construct for more than 20 years
now
but in a lot of other things one of two
things would happen either the
dependence on n would be something some
larger polynomial or
else when you try to get the error which
is inverse polynomial in n then your
dependence on epsilon is not too great
right
okay so what i'm going to do in this
talk is just show you the development of
this idea in three you know hopefully
three steps of gradually increasing
difficulty
so first we'll talk about hash functions
for load balancing this is this work by
celis reingold segev and veda
then i'll show you how to construct prgs
for combinatorial rectangles and finally
if time permits we'll talk about prgs
for half spaces all right
okay
so let's start off with the load
balancing problem so this is you know
one of the very first things that you
encounter in any course on randomized
algorithms say you throw n balls
randomly into n pins
then
with high probability no bin is going to
get more than log n volts it's actually
log n over log log n but let's ignore
that okay
so you can think of this as a hash
function where you took your jobs and
assigned them to machines or something
like that
except now you needed n login random
bits to select a truly random bin for
each ball right
is there a small family of hash
functions specified by ideally login
bits of randomness which will give you
the same kind of guarantees that no bin
is loaded too heavily
okay
so one observation is
well you can do this
by using considerably fewer random bits
by using log squared random bits
how do you do that well it's not easy
it's not hard to show it's very easy to
show that login wise independence
suffices for this right and intuitively
you're only worried about events that
involve login balls why would you need
more right we'll see this in more detail
but login wise independence suffices
and since generating a k-wise
independent random string of length n
requires seed like k log n
this immediately would tell you that
seed length log squared n is sufficient
for ensuring this max load property
right
and
perhaps surprisingly there was nothing
better known even for this very simple
load balancing problem until this work
which i'm now going to talk about which
gives you a seed length login
okay
so before i tell you
this how this result goes let's go back
to this you know this classical
uh
let's revisit this fact that log n wise
independence suffices all right
so we're throwing balls into n wins we
have n balls and n bins let's just look
at this experiment from the perspective
of one bin right so what's happening
here is that there are n balls each of
them is going to land in this bin with
probability one over n
right
so you know the number of bins in this
the number of balls that land in this
bin you know this is a poisson random
variable with mean and variance 1. so
this is a distribution we know
everything about right
so the statement we want to de-randomize
is something like this that the
probability that the load will actually
exceed log n
we would like to show that it's
polynomially small in n because if we
manage to do that we'll just do a union
bound across the various bins
okay
now there are many ways you could try
and prove this with limited independence
more or less you'll it'll amount to some
kind of higher moment computation right
so if you look at this distribution it
has mean 1 it has variance something
close to 1.
so the probability of seeing a deviation
like log n
well if you use chebyshev it'll tell you
like it's something like 1 over log n
squared right which is a fine bound but
it's not strong enough to use a union
bound now across n bins
you could use higher independence you
could use k wise independence for k some
constant you'll get 1 over log n to the
k
it's only when you use
k which is something like log n that you
get the polynomially small error that
you need in order to take a union bond
so that is why this doesn't give you
anything better than login wise
independence
okay
so now
the genius of this result was to say
well we want to throw n balls into n
bins
let's not do that quite yet let's first
throw n balls into root n bins and see
what happens right that's work enough
already for us
okay what happens now let's again look
at it from the perspective of just one
bin there's n balls coming in each of
them is going to land here with
probability 1 over root n
and now something very important happens
which is that the number of balls that's
going to land in this bin it's now
distributed like a gaussian okay
which has mean root n
and in gaussians it's always you know
it's standard to talk about mean and
variance here the variance is also root
n but what is important is the standard
deviation that's only n to the fourth
which is you know much this is the
regime we're all familiar with the
standard deviation is much smaller than
the mean
so what this means is that even to see a
load of two times root n
this is a very unlikely event right
moreover what is important for us is
that this is very easy to derandomize
because already if you just use
chebyshev's inequality it will say that
the probability of this event is going
to be something like 1 over root n so
this is not strong enough yet to use a
union bound but you can fix that by
using ky's independence for some
constant k like say k equals 10.
if you use ky's independence the
probability you'll see max load which is
much larger than say 1.1 times root n is
going to be really small it's like n to
the minus k
okay
so here something really nice is
happening which is this
in order to generate a ky's independent
random string of length n
it requires seed length which is like k
log n
and you get this k log n back in the
error exponent right whatever you invest
in the seed you're able to drive the
error down just by something exponential
in that and this is a property which is
going to be used time and again in our
constructions
okay we're not done yet we've just
thrown n balls into root n bins
but now we can iterate right we take
each of these the first step on day one
we take the n balls we throw them into
root n bins using something like 10 y's
independence
now on day 2 we come back
we look at each of these root 10 bins
and they have something like perhaps at
work slightly more than root 10 balls
for each of these bins we throw them and
to enter the one fourth pins now we're
just iterating we use different bins you
know for these root n things but we're
going to do two things firstly
since we've gone from n to root n now
we can offer to double the amount of
independence that we use because the
seed length for ky's independence
remember is k times log n if this n
becomes root n you've saved a factor of
two you can use that to increase the
amount of independence so we can double
the amount of independence we're using
within a bin
of course we have root n pins now to
take care of but we're just going to do
a union bound across these bins so we
can just use the same randomness across
bins
okay
so you keep doing this and in log login
steps you'll get done and you'll get the
right kind of load
right
so what's going on here in each step you
use order login random bits and you get
a polynomially small error bound and
this allows you to just you know there's
only log login steps here so at the end
of the day you've done the right thing
and you have polynomial inverse
polynomial error bonds
okay
so
okay
so from this i want to come up with some
kind of template that we're going to use
for constructing pseudorandom generators
now for more complicated tests even
yes
do we know
that the
used
independence it would not work no but
you know i think you could prove this
these things are you know i would ask
raghu to do it but i think it can be
done
i mean these things are pretty well
characterized in terms of the polynomial
you know the norms of the polynomials
and so on and i think here you're trying
to fool a polynomial of large norm yeah
but you know these things have they're
often notoriously tricky to prove like i
think even just epsilon bias does it
fool half spaces i don't think we really
no it doesn't
or the xrf2 epsilon bias fool's log
space so these things yeah they're
tricky
okay here's the template that i want to
you know this is the template we're
going to use
it is that if an event is predictable
right it shouldn't require much
randomness when we were throwing these n
balls into n pins and we're looking at
just one bin then there was some real
uncertainty there i going to get zero am
i going to get zero balls am i going to
get log n balls any of these things
could happen right
on the other hand when you're throwing n
balls into root 10 bins you know that
every bin is just going to have root 10
balls and you know there's some standard
deviation but it's a lower order term
right
so events like these
it's they ought to be easier to
derandomize so the template that you're
going to come up with is take some event
which is interesting
and break it into a series of
predictable events
and hope that each of these events is
easier to de-randomize by increasing the
amount of independence that you use in
each stage manually
i do understand that the difference that
you were making between uh
uh you know uh
the poisson and this thing the gaussian
yeah that's you know i'm not trying to
be formal here
i'm sorry
they're throwing into m beans but
through them i mean more senses one more
yeah because in one sense you were
dealing with the poisson distribution
right where you know you're in the
setting where mean and variance are
roughly about the same they're both
constants and you know it's
you know
limited independence is particularly
good at getting things like moment bonds
right
so in the first so i'm not trying to
prove i'm not trying to be very formal
here but in the second setting right you
were in the standard in the scenario we
are very familiar with where you have a
deviation which is much smaller the
standard deviation is much smaller than
the mean so proving a sharp
concentration result in that setting was
very simple and
yeah so i you know i'll try and make
this slightly more formal as we go along
but it's not going to be a whole lot
more firm
okay
so
i'm now going to try so this is our
template we believe that somehow events
which are you know more predictable but
there's not a whole lot happening they
should be easier to derandomize so we'll
take an event and try and break it into
a series of predictable events
is basically what you're saying if an
event is predictable then basically you
invest t bits of randomness you get two
to the minus t error
right and if an event is unpredictable
like the way then you're wasting uh
well certain okay so yeah i'm not trying
to make that formal statement quite yet
you know yeah this is just intuition but
that's the general idea that you know
okay let's see how this could work in
the setting of combinatorial rectangles
so what are those we've talked about
throwing balls into bins now we're going
to talk about taking balls out of pins
okay so here's the setting
you have n bins
each of them has some number m of balls
and you can think of n and m as being
the same if you like
each of these balls have two colors
black and white
so what we do is we reach into each bin
and we draw a ball out at random
and now the event that we're interested
in is that all the balls are black let's
see
so what is the probability of this event
well if the first bin has a pi fraction
of black balls and the second fin has a
p2 fraction it's just the product right
so
what we'd like to do is come up with a
pseudo-random strategy for drawing balls
from bins which maintains the
probabilities of events like this one
so let's be absolutely precise here
a draw of a ball from a bin you can
think of that just as a hash function
from bins which are numbered one through
n through balls in that bin which are
numbered 1 through m right so when you
draw each ball uniformly from each bin
you draw balls uniformly from every bin
then you get all the balls being black
with probability which is the product of
the pi's
but of course this requires n log m
random bits we want a hash family which
ideally uses logarithmic number of
random bits for this
so these kinds of events they go by the
name of combinatorial rectangles yeah
it's a long line of work in
pseudorandomness the nice thing about
this problem was that it was on the
critical path both for doing something
better for ac 0 and for rl okay so
there's been a considerable amount of
interest in it
and the best construction known before
our work was due to lu which gets a seed
length of log n which is great but the
dependence in 1 over epsilon was
something like log 1 over epsilon raised
to 1.5 so in the inverse polynomial
error range it was not quite log n right
and this is an extremely natural class
of tests that you could
you know this is a very natural class of
tests you imagine that it shows up in
many different settings
one that i'd like to mention is this
observation well this nice observation
of saks srinivas and zoo and zuckerman
saying that if you want to construct min
wise independent hash functions
you'll get them from a prg for
combinatorial rectangles provided you
can do you know you need this reduction
works in the range where the error
parameter is inverse polynomially small
okay so we're going to try and apply our
template of doing things gradually to
this problem
so here's what we're going to do we want
to draw one ball from each pin
well on day one we come and you know we
eliminate most of the balls we keep root
em balls from among the m balls in each
bin
and we say okay that was already a lot
of work we're done for the day
on day two we come back and we reduce
root m down to m to the one fourth and
we're done okay
we go on doing this
and log log m days later we finally have
selected one ball from each pin
okay now of course this is just a
gloriously lazy way of doing the same
process of choosing a random ball from a
bin
but the hope is that now
you don't need to use true randomness
that there's so little happening in each
stage that you know you could get away
with using limited randomness of course
you'll need to increase the amount of
randomness as time goes by
okay
so does this actually work
so let's have a look
so what happens so let's just analyze
what happens on a single day right if we
can prove that limited randomness does
the right thing here then we're more or
less done
so on day one what am i doing i had m
balls in each pin
now i'm just keeping root m balls from
among these m balls and i want to do
this using some kind of limited
independence
so what is it exactly we would like to
achieve through this process
well i'm sampling these balls from each
pin so the fraction of black balls in a
bin
that's remaining after d1 it's now a
random variable and these random
variables are correlated across bins
but if i can ensure that this product
of these random variables across bins
in expectation it does the right thing
the expectation of this product is what
it should be it's the product of the
pi's then you can imagine that we are
doing okay then if we actually did our
rest of our decisions uniformly at
random we'd be doing the right thing and
maybe we can try and de-randomize that
as well okay so this is our goal we want
that
qi which is the fraction of black balls
left in each bin this is going to be a
random variable there are going to be
correlations of course but we'd like the
product of the qi's to have the right
value yeah
are you assuming that the product of the
pis is relatively large
uh
yeah so you only care about a
pseudorandom generator with error delta
so you know if this product the pi's
becomes too small then yeah you can
assume that it's at least delta which is
the error you're shooting for
okay
so here's the good news
assume you're just sampling these balls
from within each bucket using just
pairwise independence
then of course the expectation will be
correct this is like just taking an
opinion pole right
and the variance will also be small it
reduces we know that the error in your
sampling reduces with the number of
samples that you take so the variance is
going to be something like m to the
minus 1 over square root m
that's the good news
but now we want to use limited
independence across the buckets to
multiply these q guys right and this is
the part which really sounds like crazy
talk because we know that ky's
independence it's fine when you care
about polynomials of degree k in your
random variables but here what we're
trying to fool is a polynomial of degree
n right
it almost sounds that you know it almost
seems like this shouldn't work because
if you can fool the product of
everything you know this seems like
the thing that should be hardest so then
you know you should be able to fool
anything and everything
so the thing that's going to work in our
favor is the fact that these are
actually probabilities and they're
bounded in the range 0 to 1. okay
so here's the question that we're trying
to answer if i have a product of bounded
random variables is it then true that
bounded independence suffices to
approximate
the expectation of the product you want
it to be the product of the expectations
so here's the setup i have random
variables x1 through xn each of them are
bounded in the interval 0 1.
now if they were truly independent then
i know that the expectation of the
product equals product of the
expectations i would like something like
this to be true under limited
independence
so this is a question which was already
addressed in this work of eventual which
they proved that you can get an error
bound of 2 to the minus k if you use
ky's independence
this is already surprising to me
but in fact for what we want it's not
going to be good enough because remember
we kind of want the seed length back in
the error exponent so we really want an
error x we want error like n to the
minus k out here okay
okay so you know the first thing we do
is to change the
we
we look at a more general problem let's
say the random variables are in the
range minus 1 1.
what can you say about such things
of course you're not going to get a
stronger bond because this is a more
general thing
but something more interesting happens
which is that even this theorem goes
away and you know there's a very trivial
counter example it's just parity
suppose x 1 through x n minus 1 are
uniformly random bits and then i just
take x n to be the product of x 1
through x n minus 1. right now this
distribution is n minus 1 independent
but if you compute the expectation under
the uniform distribution that is 0
whereas if you take the product of all
these things under this distribution
it's going to be constantly 1 right
so you cannot have a statement like what
they prove in this more general setting
but the good thing is that this kind of
tells you what you need to assume in
addition to have such a bound
it turns out what you need is a bound on
the total variance
right so this
the statement which i'm going to tell
you it's in this work with america and
it's kind of a real clarification of
something we were doing in the earlier
paper
we say that if you have random variables
x1 through x n which lie in the range
minus 1 1
and assume you have k y's independence
you can bound this error
by the sum of the individual variances
the total variance
raised to the power k okay
now the each of these is our random
variables in the range minus one one
their variance is a number between zero
and one
the sum of variances is some number
between zero and n okay and i've given
you a statement which is only meaningful
when the variance lies between zero and
one
in particular if the variance lies
between zero and half then we are
actually getting an improvement over
this bond right
so what this seems like something which
is extremely specific why is it of any
use
well let's go back to this setting here
it turns out just by this pairwise
independent sampling you can ensure
something much stronger than the
variance of each qi is small you can
ensure that the variance of the sum
is roughly something like 1 over m to
the point 1.
i'm not going to tell you why this is
the case you just do the calculation
carefully and then you'll see that this
is actually true okay
so now we can apply this lemma which i
showed you pretty immediately if you're
using ky's independence across buckets
then the expectation of the product it's
roughly what it should be
with an error term which is m to the
minus 0.1 k so this thing of wanting the
seed back in the exponent you actually
get that right
so
what you can do now is keep on iterating
it as you go further and further this
number m goes on dropping so you can
increase the amount of independence
while ensuring that the error stays
really small inverse polynomially small
at each stage
and log log m days later you use seed
length which is something like log n
times log log m and you're done
okay
so are
any questions about this yeah manually
reverse
i'll show you this later you know so
yeah it requires some
i mean you could just okay so basically
what's going to happen is the variance
in each bucket right so what is the
random variable you're looking at you
took independent samples you average
them out right what is the average bias
of this bucket that's the random
variable you're looking at the variance
will really look something like p i
times 1 minus p i over m over root m or
something like that so it's not just 1
over root m you have this p i times 1
minus p i factor that's why when you sum
it you actually get something it's
related to this thing russell said that
in the interesting case you can assume
that some of the pi's is not too large
if you want to see it we can do this
calculation later okay
all right so going back to this template
right so what this tells us is that
we can try maybe here is one
here's one attempt at formalizing what
predictable ought to mean if you have a
sequence of variables where the total
variance is not too large
then maybe there you can get away with
limited independence okay
so now we're going to use this template
and apply it to constructing prgs for
half spaces
though in fact i'm going to talk about
not half spaces but a more general class
of functions which
you've probably not heard of before
because we just defined them in this
paper which hasn't appeared yet they're
called
so we call them fourier shapes
so what are fourier shapes it's again
the setting where you're drawing balls
from bins
but now the balls have colors right
they're allowed to have infinitely many
colors
and in fact these colors are going to be
coming from the unit complex disk
so each ball has a color
the color is a complex number of norm at
most one right
so okay so each ball has a certain color
now what do you do
you draw these balls from the bins okay
so you have a complex number for each of
these balls
and then you multiply them together
right since you know multiplication in
the complex plane is essentially
rotation you can think of this as mixing
all the colors together
and then you finally get a color which
is obtained by taking this product it's
also going to be a number in the unit
complex disk
okay
and now what do i want to do
like before i want a small family of
hash functions that fools this
collection of somewhat esotric functions
but only in expectation okay so let me
just tell you why this is something
non-trivial
so this color is finally going to be
some random variable distributed on the
unit complex disk let's say it's uniform
and plus and minus 1.
its expectation is some other complex
number
and all i want is that when i draw these
balls pseudorandomly the expectation i
get is close to this expectation
i'm not asking to get the distribution
right and you know this is an important
difference because for instance there
are so many ways of getting expectation
zero in this and they are all the same
as far as this definition goes
okay so we started off by saying we
wanted max load in every bin to be small
then we said we wanted to fool the
probability of some event now we're
fooling the expectation of some complex
valued random variable why would you
care to do that okay
it turns out that this can encode a lot
of things which
are they're pretty much in rl these are
classes of natural functions that you
need to fool in order to get a
pseudorandom generator for randomized
log space
one example is modular test so these are
things where you get to sum up subsets
of bits but then you take it mod some
you know modulus and this could be a
pretty large modulus of size like root n
right so this is a generalization of
parity and so on
in the large modulus case we didn't know
how to fold these things with small
seedlings
half spaces is another example which can
be half spaces are just linear
classifiers this is another example of a
class of functions which
you know it's received a lot of
attention and it turns out these fourier
shapes capture half spaces
combinatorial shapes what are these
let's go back to the case where there's
only two colors of balls in each bin
now i draw balls from every bin and then
i have some function on the number of
black balls i could say i want it to be
even i want it to be at least 10 or
something like that so it's a fairly
natural class of functions
so it turns out that fooling fourier
shapes suffices to fool all these
classes of functions yeah
oh yes it's the yeah it's this thing
right here it's
you have a coordinate function each of
which it maps one through m to a unit
complex number it's the color within
each pin and then i just take the
product across bins
sorry yeah these are fourier shapes
the individual expectations yeah
exactly oh sorry yeah lots of notation
showing up sneakily yeah so i have these
coordinate functions for each coordinate
and then what i do is if i pick randomly
i get some kind of distribution here i
look at the expectation of that now i
want to be able to draw pseudo-randomly
such that when i take the product i have
roughly the same expectation
so let me just tell you one thing about
where this connection comes from it
comes from the discrete fourier
transform right
let's say you're thinking about half
spaces
you
what this essentially means is that you
have some weighted sum of 0 1 random
variables they are weighted by some
integers you're looking at their sum you
want to understand the distribution of
this random variable
now it's an integer random variable and
its fourier transform at some value
theta is going to be given by
the exponential of i theta times the
random variable you do this usual trick
if you have a sum in the exponent you
turn it into a product and what you'll
get here is a fourier shape okay so i'm
not going to tell you more about this
but basically we are kind of trying to
fool functions by looking at their
fourier transform that's what's going on
here
all right
so what we give is a generator for
fourier shapes which has seed length
which is you know logarithmic in all the
relevant parameters which is the
alphabet m the dimension n and this
error parameter one over epsilon we are
hiding some log log squared terms here
okay
and maybe in the next five four minutes
i'm just going to give you a very high
level idea of how the generator for this
thing works and how it generalizes what
we've seen already
okay the first thing to observe is that
high variance so you know it's going to
be all about the variance and the first
observation is that high variance lowers
expectations what do i mean by this
let's say we have a random variable in
the unit circle and it has high variance
which means it's all over the circle
right
so you'd imagine that this naturally
pulls the center of mass so the
expectation is just the center of mass
of these points and you imagine this
pulls the center of mass towards the
center so if the variance is very high
then the expectation is small in
magnitude and you can actually prove
that it's a simple calculation
okay so this tells us something about
the expectation of any fourier shape
like this under the uniform distribution
you would actually be taking the product
of the individual expectations
now every time one of these fjs has high
variance its expectation is going to be
small so the overall expectation goes
down a little bit
so if the total variance is high the
expectation of the fourier shape is
going to be small in magnitude right
so this is useful because all we want to
do is to fold these things in
expectation so all we need to ensure is
that our prg also gives us an
expectation which is close to zero right
so i won't say a whole lot about how
this is done you know the kind of
fourier shape you should have in mind
for this is just parity functions
naturally the prg is some extension of
the hour and hour construction of
epsilon bias sets you need to choose the
right construction you know the one
where they do gradual amplification they
basically build it with their bare hands
it turns out that you can lift that
construction to this more general
setting
the interesting case is where the
variance is small okay and i'm just
going to focus on the case where the
alphabet within each pin is of size 2.
this corresponds to the case where the
inputs are bits depending on the input
you get either this or that complex
number from each pin
all right so the first thing we're going
to do simply because it's worked for us
in every example we've seen so far is to
just hash these n
coordinates into root n bins which
contain roughly the right number of
coordinates in each pin so let's say we
hash them into root n bins each of them
contains root n coordinates
what do we do within each bin
let's say we know how to solve the root
n dimensional problem we have a very
good prg for it we're going to use that
within each pin right now the real
tricky question is what are we going to
do across bins because there are root n
of them so if you use independent seeds
then your overall seed is going to be
root n times log n and you don't want to
do that
okay
so now the key idea is you can think of
a pseudorandom generator for the root n
dimensional case as a gadget which takes
a fourier shape over an alphabet 2 and
dimension root n and converts it into
one single shape but over a much larger
alphabet right
because what is a prg for these things
after all
if you actually pick one item from each
of these bins you're going to get some
distribution on 2 to the root 10 complex
numbers
the prg is just replacing this with a
smaller collection of size poly n
perhaps such that the expectation is
roughly the same so if all you care
about is expectations you can take this
routine dimensional object
replace it by one fourier shape
but it needs to be over a much larger
alphabet now the alphabet size will be
two to the seed length okay
all right so with this view we can think
that we have taken these
n fourier shapes and we've reduced it to
the problem of fooling root n of them
but over a much larger alphabet right
and now we want to know how do we
recycle seeds for these things
but this is why it's nice to work with a
larger alphabet because what you have
now is just one fourier shape in root n
dimensions but over a much larger
alphabet so instead of choosing
independent seeds for each of these
things
you can recycle the seeds using a
pseudorandom generators now
for a larger alphabet in root 10
dimensions okay
so in essence what you're trying to do
when you have independent seeds is just
to fool this fourier shape which is in
root 10 dimensions and over a large
alphabet so you can just recycle these
seeds using a prg
so in essence what we've done is to
reduce the problem of constructing prgs
for an alphabet of two in n dimensions
to an alphabet which is huge think of
this as n to the thousand but in root n
dimensions
so is this really progress
well perhaps not yet but we can reduce
this alphabet using this kind of
repeated sampling that we used in the
case of combinatorial rectangles so
we'll in the first stage we'll sample
square root m from each bucket 2 to the
r will become 2 to the r over 2.
you go on doing this and in log log m
steps you'll actually have made progress
you'll have radius 2 comma n to 2 comma
root 10 okay
so this is of course a very you know
fast and furious description
it's not even clear from this why low
variance should have anything to do with
anything at all
and it turns out the main technical
lemma that you'll use time and again in
proving that this actually works and it
does actually work
is this generalization of this lemma we
had earlier to numbers which are bounded
in the unit complex disk that if you
take the product of
variables which have low variance then
ky's independence is sufficient to fill
them in expectation
all right so um
so let me just summarize by saying that
so this technique it's you know it's a
pretty in retrospect a fairly simple and
natural technique even if proving it
takes some effort sometimes
and it seems to do a lot of things that
we knew we needed to do in order to make
progress on these problems like you know
constructing better prgs for rl
now i hope that this will actually be
applicable to more things but it's you
know so here is where we are stuck at as
far as rl goes we can fool a lot of
functions but they all have this
property like take a half space
these are not exactly in log space but
they are well approximated by log space
things and this holds irrespective of
the order in which you see the bits the
same for things like mod tests and so on
and so forth
everything that we fool we can only we
seem to be only able to fool functions
which are going to be in log space no
matter what order you see the bits in
right
and
you know it's it's a real challenge to
see whether you can do anything for
things which are only in log space when
the bits arrive in the right order
now for ac zero we are able to fool read
ones cnfs and dnfs because read once you
know it naturally means that in
computing the expectation there's some
product going on and you can imagine
that all the technology we have is very
useful for that
could this do anything beyond the read
once case you know if it could can it
fool all cnfs for instance that would be
really nice
and finally just you know the fact that
in order to compute the expectation of
the product you don't need full
independence you know i think this is a
somewhat surprising fact a lot of times
in the analysis of algorithms why using
independence is because you have some
expectation of products and you want to
be able to compute it so maybe the fact
that there's a natural setting where you
can get away with limited independence
hopefully it could find other
algorithmic applications
all right so let's stop right thanks